that's not it
is
i want to wish you a merry christmas
like people ask me this all the time
like how do you do voices like how can i
do voices uh it's just a lot of practice
like i grew up watching a lot of tv so i
was like you know always mimicking the
voices that i heard on tv
and uh
just like watch a lot of like
if you're focusing on like one voice
just like watch a lot of footage of that
and just like
in person like you know just
like how it sounds in your head just
like uh
records yourself put on youtube you know
gets people's reactions like that's how
i do it you know
yeah like i just didn't think much of it
like i'm not gonna do this for a living
someday you know i always wanted to do
like
like my own cartoons i didn't even think
of voices
but yeah like the reactions were pretty
good like i remember doing
uh mr mackey
mr mike even good
like i think seventh grade
and people loved it so
um
well i went to college for uh animation
and uh i just didn't like it and i took
a class on video production
and i
fell in love with it and youtube was
fairly new
around the time i think this was back in
0.6 like youtube was a year old but you
know how many people knew about it and
uh
i don't know i just started putting like
my school projects up on there and
started doing like impression videos and
just kind of took off from there
like i did a video called uh
100 voices in under 10 minutes
which since i've removed just because
it's bad
and uh
some other guy did like 100 voices in
under five minutes
and i you know i was like oh he ripped
me off he did like so and so amount of
voices and so on so time so i kind of
try to one up and you know like young
cocky me
so i did 101 in like under four minutes
so
that's the story behind that
i just wrote down like a bunch of like
voices that i did well or semi well and
just kind of
you know wrote a line for each one like
i had note cards like if you if you
watch the video you can say like i look
down
you know a bunch and you know i'm
looking at note cards because it's kind
of impossible to memorize all that by
going that fast so
like it was it got featured on myspace
when that still existed uh it got like a
million views and
i don't know like a few days so
it was pretty it was a pretty big deal
at the time
myspace
like if it weren't for youtube i don't
know what i'd be doing i really don't
like the youtube's done a lot
for my for my career um
yeah
i don't
i'd still be in colorado probably
i have no idea
yeah i just moved in july so been out of
about five
four or five months
you know i've been like meeting with a
bunch of people here and just like
collaborating with other youtubers like
a bunch of youtubers live out in la so i
think it's like the best decision i've i
think i've made is to move out here just
to
you know get my name out there more and
get into voice acting you know that's my
goal
been doing a lot with jax films
um
what else
i've been getting a lot of like
sponsorship deals like through big frame
it's like i did this uh
i can't really talk about it but i did
like this this food
show
uh on monday we filmed that
so uh that should be going up uh next
probably like january i would say it was
like it's like a cooking show and i was
like a guest
so that was pretty cool um
trying to think of what else i've done
mostly just jackson's cause like he
lives nearby so it's pretty easy
seven a.m waking up in the morning gotta
be fresh
gotta go downstairs that was a it's a 40
million now
had no idea that it would get that much
um
that was my first dub like i just this
friday thing was big and i'm like you
know i have to do something with this
like this was back when i was like broke
i was like in debt
and like this kind of like
it's funny to say that rebecca black
kind of made my career
or at least
put me out there you know
so uh
like i was just like
recording the voiceovers for friday it
took me like two hours and i i got tired
with him like i don't i want to do the
whole thing so i'm like
i'll just make him drive off a cliff
so i was originally gonna dub the whole
thing but like i think
i think it's better that i kept it short
like if i did the whole thing i don't
think it would have been hit as it is
i don't think i don't know i think
people have gotten bored with it like
two minutes on
hey peter do you have a screwdriver i
could borrow
that's i think that's one of my
favorites just because like no one
really does it
that well i mean mine's not perfect but
it's better than a lot of the people on
on the youtube i guess
um
well i have like a list of ideas that
i've you know wanted to do for years i
just want like i just i don't know
randomly think of ideas and just write
them down and kind of
go back to it like elaborate on it and i
sometimes i write up a script sometimes
i just improvise it sometimes it's like
half and half
and then
then i film it
and then i edit it
and that's pretty much it like i just do
everything myself like sometimes i i
hire like uh like music guys like i have
a music guy that does music for me kind
of
like other than that it's just me
and uh
you know i've started to do cartoons
like i have a cartoon in the works
like i had i hired an animator and uh
i think i'm gonna start doing those more
often because i kind of have the budget
to do that i've you know been wanting to
do that for years so
like i just want to do like more variety
because i get bored i get bored easily
like on projects if i do like just the
same thing over and over again i have to
do like different
like all over the spectrum kind of stuff
um just like cartoons and i want to do
like a like a choose your own adventure
type video because those were those were
big like a few years ago and i just i
haven't really seen any sense and like i
you know i've always wanted to do one
and uh
whatever stuff
like i have this uh video called uh
this video series called the twisted
fate of chapula strange and i kind of
want to like elaborate more on that and
like have a budget and just like turn it
into like a
just like a revenge like a revenge flick
i don't know if you've seen those
but it basically it's about this guy
from the 1930s and he commits this crime
or he's like framed or something and
he's uh
cryogenically frozen
and like he's thought out once a year to
sing the worst songs of the past year
so it's like you know like it's this
twisted fate so like i do like one every
year and like he sings all the just the
worst songs like nicki minaj
and just stuff like that so i kind of
want to i kind of want to like gradually
turn it into like a revenge flick with
like a budget and stuff like that's my
dream i just want to do something like
that
just put yourself out there like uh
and just practice and uh
it's like really hard for
it's like really hard to get seen on
youtube now like it's it's changed so
much over the years uh i think i was
lucky enough to like
hit it like when impersonations were big
like back in 0.607 and
i mean they could they could still be
big now it just depends on like
just like try to hit like something
popular like something like
you know like uh
topical
i guess
like uh like lately it's like the like
the bane like the bane impressions you
know those those are pretty big like i
did a video called uh
being played slender and it's like
almost like two million views
just like oh
slender you think darkness is your ally
you know stuff like that
i'm brock baker and you've just watched
my interview with new media rock stars
check me out on youtube.comgoiter
brock's dubs youtube.com even made a
shirt
are you crazy
so uh yeah